welcome to your mom's house
I don't like the sweater oh I don't like
that like at all so instead of fact
you're not saying fuck boy yeah yeah
it's the PC version of faggot okay I'm
turning purple
that was my request fucking traitor
Ruben damn you bird hey look at GG
lennie time what happen I know I broke
him today I broke him today I knocked
this over but look here's the good news
there's that GG hold on
then there's mini gg
all right back in business if you don't
have a backup GG Allin bobblehead you
better get your life if you're a real
fan you have your primary and then your
backup can't believe you fucking did
that no but I can't say faggot I'm gonna
say fuck boy had to isolate it huh
three times you had to do it had to
catch me on that that's my favorite one
yeah hey if I can't say faggot I got a
fuck-boy guys my documentaries coming
out can't we take a joke yeah lumen had
released the summer samuel golden mayor
picked it up i saw actually a lot of
people talking about it online supposed
to be really great i narrated it's not
my documentary ted bellacor directed it
- re paying if you're offended by that
what you just heard me say about fuck
boys don't go see that document a lot of
fuck boy responses this week - is that
right yeah people oh they're like that's
not a replacement for what Tom it's not
a replacement if I can't say faggot I'm
gonna say like okay for what huh all
right they're like no it's not it's
fucking stupid it of course it is you
guys are fucking fuck boys for saying
it's 100% and that's what it sounds like
it is I mean the origin of fuck-boy is
prison okay all right yeah
and it's somebody who people would fuck
their hence it's a replacement yeah it's
a guy you fuck it's not it's not
necessarily a replacement for the the
literal pejorative homosexual slang what
I'm saying is that it's replacing in the
lexicon something that people want to
angrily shout right right with the
intention of being to take someone down
accuse them of being lesser than whether
that be effeminate or just a bitch right
it's a it's a heightened version of
bitch but it's also something that you
can yell freely basically yeah it's an
acceptable form it totally and it will
become politically in krandall you fuck
boys they disagree or fuck boys that's
our side